[音楽]
こんにちははじめ社長です今日は何とあの
か方のページにお越しいただいておりますよね
[音楽]
同走しますテレビの奥の人です
ふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇ4つずつで応援してたん
でうわ音程鹿追できて光栄です
準備やんですけどいいましたというわけなんですけども
今日はちょっとなぁ稼動選手頭悪そうございます
ございました
まあもう普通にサッカーしても勝つ見込みはゼロだと思うんでちょっといろいろ
とんでもないハンデよ
労働政治にかましていきながら何とかして僕が勝つたいなと思っております
負けませんよ大歩危ませんせっかくの3本勝負なので買ったら
長友選手の山入りのボールとか言ったらモチロンも白い
白いですよ
鷹羽します豪華買ったら眠れますあの同選手が経ったら僕の動画見てる人思ったらよく
知ってると思うけど
どんどんぬいぐるみ受けますよ本当に時間本当ですか
これをな方をせずに済みませんプレゼントいたしますあれ出すかします
で僕もちょっとてお腹本気で言いましょう戦いてる
鉄火のでキャブねー本気で戦いたいと思いますのでよろしくお願いますお願いしまーす
さあ
ちょっと勇気で1本目は dk 対決ですハンデとしてば普通にやっても欠かせないと
思って
5本勝負で
佐藤選手がマイナス鑑定
美味しかった
なホテルなん
俺は高校時代得点王とオフサイドだったので
実力が備えていると思いますいう
じゃあ1本目いきます
いますいい
[拍手]
car
アルェーだったってハンデです ok
俺いけるワーク行ってお姉さん
ん
そうだえん
うぇい
はぁ
てるだろ
反応できなかったことだけでも
コンビだしますよもうちょっと-22体ゼロなんでまだいいとしています
だ日本でいきます
[音楽]
はぁ
ビバばさーああ結構
いいとも出ると思ったんですけど頑張っはあああ
あああああ
ああああああああ
yeah
それぞれにはでは許せず
行かずですよねうかちですこれで今-9-1-9-いた以上ですけど大丈夫まだ立って
います
3本目いきます
ええええええ
やばいさあてもそうでしょエットってあげるとか
これで決めたらゼロなところみるん
ここはならない
はぁ
[拍手]
ここ乗客があの弊害から
入ってない入りましたん
はぁ
こっちか
いやぁいやぁ
ワールドは4名います
[音楽]
いやー先見れるんですよやましい個まとめ
俺決めたらでゼロかじゃずーっと俺が決めたら
[音楽]
持った
おっ
はぁ
ありません
ええええ
それ
最後の声にポン酢
おっしゃー
どうすれば取れるのかっ
米ちゃえる挙げられる
切るん
公明います
re re
ああああああ
マッハん
ん座って本当に誰だとれないですねっ
これがきた
楽園使い止めないじゃあそれでこれで終わりだ
ありますよハロー
たーーーえっ
たあああ
湿った
ています
uh
wh
ちょっとショボすぎ
いやでもまだ始まってまったりなんです3本そうなんでなんだ取れず1本目ま
生魚にかかりましたかー
まあ1本目山な方もあの総理ということでございましています
まだまだ相場とちょっとばかりなんで2本目は
でスティック対決0
は車 of へこれを読む
これを普通になっては勝てないということでなどんですよ
-100回かと思った後まあまあなるほど全然あるもスターですか
レンズがいるぞ
など選手の前でダサいとか見せられねぇ
いきます
[音楽]
rar
アーチャー
3階ですそうだから俺は104回するボールをカチッ
お願います4型だが大丈夫なん
いますお願いしますえっ
[音楽]
もしありがとう
ana b 2 b 3 b ミュン
えっ
競ってきた絶対が出るという
邪魔しユーザー重視し中国
救助経営
プードゥドゥ pou dou dou
ラブライブ he はい
ああああああああ
voodoo
yeah
nend
ハーシー a
3本目はいい
[音楽]
ブーバーロス過ぎ祭り対決しましょうパー4
7倒産が公式サポーターに集変えればということでなぜか強いんですか
めちゃくちゃつですねちょっと最後だけ僕勝ちたいんで無理ですよ
いや絶対勝ちますまあでもねー僕は出るまでもないんで
まあ3本目のそのぶっちゅーる町の対決は強力な助っ人を呼んでますよぷっ uso
ハッハッハー千葉商プロ相撲
助っ人ロス
数しかないで僕は使ってまあ逆していきましょうはいはいやっていきましょう
前節撫でて猫の物的にまってなんと円座というプラットフォームを打ってやっているん
で
アプリを行けばいいそうブラウザーゲームねー
名護容量にせず遊べるゲームになっております新しい
さっそくバトルしていきましょうはい行きましょうじゃあ僕
孫悟空で私方もと痛感してベジタできますね
i have 方強いいねえ
えっの
8枚のカードが何でもいい今井功輝
でどっちかを選んで出していくというバトルになっておりますたい数字がただ違法攻撃
できるんですよねはいそう
めっちゃ考えるじゃないだけどよくモード選んだ最後は勝ちたいじゃあ止めちゃスキル
とか見てくださっては
ねああああああああ界王様
yeah
水墨画市で後だったので僕は講座にもでしたね
4ん
ほらっ hey 気円斬だな
ずんダメージ無効クリーン使ったからちょっと怖いん
そうです彼はそうそう指定
[音楽]
祖父はもう使ってきたうーんけどねぇ
これクリンガー
サポート役にいるから使えるかとクリーンだったら返信します
早速パーサーずにバターレーズンん
後半失速タイプだと思う赤い説明するねそうでこっちは常勤
よし
k うちもありません
を受けた1位
うっ
は ja
よし
きっていうのがたまでわかると思うんですけどこれを使うと数字でつなぎれるんです
ドキッ
どうだと
ますよしを取られますあぁん
これミスってまいります多分ミスってる攻撃しない奴の木を挙げたからこれ何か寝てる
気がする
できる
順調2003年やってるけど
必須のやるまでなかったそうですね
少しあっえっ
us だよブーンスーパーさんにポットを見てきたじゃあメイアーねぇねぇ
毛先やがって
なんだからここにあったよしこっからなんですよ本気になりました
バイトル的な安動きが怪しいん
2月大学
今結構5000リープしてるんで
ちゃまいる bye bye 説明になります
6流れません
それはああああ
一つ太郎
はっはっはっはっしゃい lea
またが無駄になってるわけじゃないこれ攻撃力めっちゃ汁だ
見てますこの合戦 bp を見てますが発生
4これは結構もうザクザク入ってねーよ多分
攻めていけるよねっあれ
一枚じゃこの格好さん
なく権獲得いやブッダに編んでももならでも弔問いると国家だが強い
負けるんだ
そうだんです
歓迎きたネオなエロ
第二台持ち綺麗なキュッ
俺はす
てっ
渋谷ロってくれた怒っ
きたね俺が終わりアジャの
だけ
こっからなぁでもいい
18000た6500ですね
これはでもせ返納する
まずエンド入りまーす
先輩たちはでかいいますでかぜうまえん
取れません
まぁでもまだゴッセンだろう
うっ
ここで決まるかっ
はい売れるんじゃなんだよあやばい磯貝ま
ちょっともちろんラウンドすごい延長戦見てなってきてる
なんだ今の彼はを
あーちょっと待っても立ち対応アーメンそして3日わー
[音楽]
ああ怖いこれと1超強いよって苦痛
これは食らうけどこれは誰かいいパンツで飛ばされるとかないやそれではないでしょ
1回とかないよね
超本気二葉ベジータ超本気だよ
レンズ付校に計やっぱりでももうパッ
rear
祖母山つ酷く
3回降臨でくださいまあ紙幣
ep カードすぎやいいねぇや3回攻撃はぜってーしょんでー
[音楽]
23これだったらくださってください
here 22勝1敗が消え1 r ねドローンもぜひあつっに行きリスございます
ぜひ遊んでみてください
でまぁソフト
いろんなアイテムがが者ができますのでオススメです
ぜひ今遊んでみてください動画の概要欄にすぐ遊べるリンクがありますのでぜひ遊んで
みてくださいそしてなんと長友選手が公式サポーター就任をきれいして3人のサイン
入りのボールのプレゼントキャンペーンを実施しておりまーす
1個のボールにね3つ書いてあるじゃないか
を先取北3-3階のしております
キャンペーンの詳しい内容も概要欄に上げますので是非皆さんチェックしてみて
ください
そしてなか同選手のヒカキンさんの動画もすでにありますので
はいどうもぜひ見てください一禁じ日にありますのでぜひ今日本当にありがとうござい
ましたし
はぁ
ちょっと最近サッカーボール買ったんでリベンジしていた
メッシュ頑張ります有名してくださいありがとうございました
イメージしますあってを待っしちゃったバイバイ
はい
ああああああ
car
[音楽]
teal
yeah
あっはぁ